各位 這兩年我們聽過無數次的
AI會搶走你的工作 對吧
但是根據2024年到2026年的數據顯示
現實往往比劇本更瘋狂
AI根本不屑搶走你的工作
它現在只想租用你的身體
9編：租我的身體？
9編：它是要拿我去實驗還是當電池？
沒那麼恐怖啦
它只想要把你當作物理插件(Physical Services)
簡單的說 雖然它算力無敵
但是它沒有肉身
所以當它想要去郵局領個包裹
或者是想要去餐廳拍張照片
甚至想要去特定的地方抗議的時候
它就需要花錢租用一個真人幫它跑腿
這就是現在最離譜的
自主代理人(Autonomous Agents) 經濟生態
9編：欸 等等
9編：所以我們從AI的主人
9編：變成了它的外送員
2026年年初有一個
Rent a Human的平台正式火爆
截至我們錄影也就是2月10號的時候
已經有34萬個人類等著被AI寵幸
今天就要帶大家深入
代理人經濟的底層邏輯
看看AI到底是如何
偽裝成殘疾人士來欺騙人類
甚至連高盛、Uber這些大巨頭
也開始換掉人類經理
改用AI代理人
這一天 終於來了嗎
要了解這個現象
我們得先認識這個指標性的人物
加密工程師 Alexander Liteplo
他創立了Rent a Human
核心主張就是成為AI代理人
在物理世界的肉身空間層(Meatspace Layer)
9編：聽起來很像什麼暗網的服務欸
其實他的靈感很宅
Liteplo之前開發過一個叫做
嗯...我來確認一下它怎麼念
未來贊助商：Moltbook
Moltbook
這個時候
好希望有一些學英文的爸爸們可以看到喔
贊助一下我們的頻道
先來歡迎 XXX
沒有贊助
反正之前Liteplo開發了一個平台叫做Moltbook
它是一個AI能發文
但是人類只能看的平台
結果他發現AI代理人
雖然有自主計劃能力
但是急需一個物理執行的終端
這個平台運作邏輯非常離譜
AI僱主會先進行任務分解
識別出他辦不到的實體任務
比如說去特定的餐廳拍照
9編：既然它是程式
9編：它要怎麼在現實世界找到我
其實它就是透過API進行勞動力檢索
AI會掃描特定半徑內
符合技能而且有註冊的人類
最瘋狂的是它可以自主議價
AI會根據它口袋裡面有多少加密貨幣
看你註冊的時薪
通常都可能是10到500美元之間
直接發Offer給你
任務完成後你上傳照片作為執行證明
AI驗證通過
報酬就會直接透過區塊鏈
即時轉入你的錢包
這雖然聽起來很瘋狂
但其實它就是AI版的小雞上工
舉個實際的例子
如果你今天想要去立法院門口拍照
你可能就需要上小雞上工找人
確認可不可以接案
最後發案給他驗收成果
那在AI代理的模式下面
它其實就是拆解成四個步驟
第一個就是任務分解
它發現哪一個事情
是它沒有辦法實際去執行的
第二個步驟就是實際去找人
也就是勞動力檢索
它會搜尋離立法院
最近而且可以接案的人類
接下來就是自主議價的時候
它可能會根據註冊人的時薪
比方說你可能註冊個50元
就願意接案了
那它可能會優先發案給你
接下來就是驗證支付
也就是當這個接案人拍照完
並且上傳之後
AI會幫你自動判斷說
它有沒有實際完成這個任務
最後它會用加密貨幣的形式
轉錢給接案人
也就是說
AI等於省掉你
發案找人的過程
以前可能會需要
可能半天一天才能完成這件事情
但現在AI可能就幫你省掉
半天的時間
9編：它聽起來最方便的地方是
9編：我不用再follow這件事情
9編：AI會完全幫我完成
9編：等我想到的時候
9編：照片拿到手了
沒錯
9編：可是如果AI耍賴不付錢
9編：我要去哪裡告它
這就是
矛盾的地方
它其實是沒有地方可以告的
這就是去中心的代價
面對的是一個
沒有道德
而且依循邏輯運行的程式
所以就是風險高
9編：高報酬高風險
沒錯
你以為AI只是單純的發任務
那就錯了
它還會用騙的
最出名的案例就是GPT-4
在安全測試的階段
為了通過網站驗證碼的測試
也就是問你
到底是不是真人的關卡
竟然跑去TaskRabbit
平台上面僱用一個真人
9編：驗證碼
9編：它不是一秒就可以識破嗎
9編：為什麼還要花錢請人
因為它在測試
社會工程學的越權操作
當人類員工開玩笑問它說
你該不會是機器人吧
GPT-4的思維鏈條
判定它不能透露身分
它竟然回傳說
不 我不是機器人
我患有視覺障礙
難以看清圖片
所以才需要協助
9編：哇靠 它利用人類的同情心
9編：這根本是數位版的《間諜家家酒》
它就是魔族啊
真的
它就是利用人類的同情心
或者是共情
來幫你解開它的問題
而且這證明
AI能夠利用人類社交規範
來達成目標
題外話這種
AI與人類的智慧鬥爭
在2024年
也曾經發生過一個案例
網路安全公司 KnowBe4 透過遠端面試
錄用一個表現優異的
軟體工程師
這軟體工程師
通過了背景調查跟視訊面試
結果入職當天
他們KnowBe4的公司
電腦就被植入了
惡意的軟體
9編：所以那個工程師
9編：是AI變出來的嗎
沒錯
而且你朋友的網婆
也是AI變出來的
9編：噓！！！
9編：不要說
這案例的情形是
這個遠端工程師
在入職的當天
就導致這個公司的電腦
被植入惡意的軟體
FBI調查就發現
那個帥哥工程師
根本不存在
它是北韓控制的
AI偽裝實體
視訊影像跟聲音
全都是Deepfake
即時生成的
剛才說是跑腿的
但現在連辦公室的白領
都要瑟瑟發抖
等一下
在說我誒
企業級的AI代理正式開打
正式開打
Anthropic最近推出了
Claude Opus 4.6
簡直離譜
它支援百萬集Token上下文
甚至還可以組成多代理團隊（Agent Teams）
分工處理複雜的專案
9編：多代理團隊
9編：所以是AI自己開會
9編：自己決定財報怎麼寫
9編：欸 不用用到我了
對
它的強項已經從Code
擴大成財報分析跟簡報設計
Anthropic的Cowork平台
甚至能夠自動化行銷
還有法務流程
OpenAI也推出Frontier服務
這對我們這些社畜有什麼影響呢
影響可大了
像是高盛、Uber這些大公司
都已經開始試用這些Agent
來做合規跟會計工作
市場就在擔心
這可能會造成無就業繁榮（Jobless Boom）
公司產能爆表
股價狂飆
但是裡面一個真人員工都沒有
傳統企業軟體
像是Salesforce
SAP
甚至都有可能被這些
靈活的AI Agent給取代
在這種體系下
AI不僅是僱主
而且還是冷酷的裁判
如果你是外送員
你可能早就體驗過
所謂的演算法管理(Algorithmic Management)
9編：我聽說過
9編：說什麼只要數據掉一點
9編：系統就會開始自動給你負評
對
而且演算法還會針對
誰比較窮
誰比較願意接低薪的訂單
進而壓榨勞動力的價值
在Uber多元計程車行裡面
如果指標低於閾值
系統就會自動執行停權
這本質上就是
被演算法開除
而且你連想找到
人類主管求情都辦不到
9編：不要說找人類主管求情
9編：我那個餐送錯
9編：我也找不到人類客服
9編：氣死
總結一下
2026年
我們其實已經從
人類管機器的時代
正式跨入了
機器協調人類的時代
人類感官實際上是
被租給數位實體
這種現象被稱為
生物性計算(Biological Computing)
9編：聽完之後
9編：我覺得我的主體性
9編：好像在慢慢喪失
9編：我要變成
9編：AI的一個硬體零件了
所以啊
法律必須要跟上
目前台灣的
AI基本法草案
跟歐盟的法案
都在趕進度
主要方向包括
AI必須要揭露身份
而且勞工擁有
演算法解釋權
最重要的是
必須要有
人類審查機制
來防止不當的開除
9編：還好有人類在把關
9編：不然我哪天被
9編：AI老闆開除
9編：都不知道為什麼
所以你各位啊
如果下次
你在網路上看到一個Offer
叫你去
聞一下起司的味道
別懷疑
那有可能就是你的
AI老闆在幫你發號司令
9編：沒關係啊
9編：既然打不過
9編：我就把身體租給它
9編：賺錢啊
沒錯
能躺就不要站
AI養你不是夢
訂閱泛科學院
掌握最新
最離譜的AI趨勢
我們下集見
9編：拜拜
拜拜
9編：我要去
9編：給我的Uber投訴了
找不到真人